[Music]
folks who take a growth mindset see the
challenges they're facing as something
that they could develop enough to
achieve or overcome or master or learn
from so that a failure from a growth
mindset perspective is an opportunity to
learn one of the things that goes on
when you are learning in the context of
a number of other people who are
different from you you're confronted
with experiences that you would never
have had now if you're in a group with a
lot of people who look and have very
different experiences and now you begin
to share those experiences you gain from
that living knowledge about what it is
like to be a very different person and
they're saying well here's what happened
when we used that approach and somebody
else will raise their hand and say yeah
but here's what happened when we use
that approach and they're so different
and that's incredibly educational from a
developmental perspective it makes you
begin to realize things that you have
been taking for granted or possibilities
that you've never considered I remember
hearing a Ukrainian mass retailer
comparing what was going on in his
organization to an executive from
Lululemon the end the learning that came
out of that interaction was amazing that
diversity allows you to start thinking
of possibilities and remember it's
thinking of possibilities that makes it
possible for us to engage in the
developmental approach to work push your
subjects
and explore new approaches to leadership
explore Stanford's upcoming programs